the latest in the Russia investigation
the FISA memo released by house Intel
Democrats over the weekend has some key
differences from the one released a few
weeks ago by the Republicans Democrats
said the FISA warrant made only narrow
use of that phony Russian dossier and
Republicans claimed there would have
been no warrant without it the two sides
also disagree of whether the FBI
informed the court of the political
origins of the document which was paid
for by the DNC and the Hillary Clinton
campaign so who's telling the truth
let's debate it with Republican
Congressman Matt Gaetz a member of the
House Judiciary Committee and Felipe
Ramos who is the former senior advisor
Secretary of State Hillary Clinton don't
laugh difference pronunciation air well
I like to keep you guessing let's talk
about what the this memo said I mean the
Democrats were kind of celebrating over
the weekend congressman gates they say
that look it really wasn't the reason
this Russian investigation began they
were surveilling Carter page for some
time then the Papadopoulos information
came up in the summer of 2016 so the
Republicans are you know making a
mountain out of a molehill
what's most fascinating Laura is what's
not in the Democratic memo the
fundamental premise of our argument is
that cash at the Democratic National
Committee was convertible into a
government sponsored warrant to spy on
American citizens and surprisingly the
Democratic memo does not say Hillary
Clinton's name once and it doesn't
mention the DNC once and so I think it's
pretty evident that there are a lot of
the Republican claims that are actually
bolstered by the Democratic memo
including the fact that the dossier was
used to get this warrant and that a
yahoo news article planted by
Christopher Steele was also served as a
validating basis for the fake dossier
it's shameful felt like that well Laurie
I am I've learned a last couple of
months that if I'm gonna play poker is
someone there are four people I want to
play with Donald Trump
congressman gets gates Jim Jordan you
started this and Devin Nunez
because these guys where their fear on
their sleeve when they yell memo when
they introduce legislation it means they
know what's coming literally they
probably have a heads-up but they know
that there's a problem in this case
I'll let you at reduced release which in
the previous case when you called for
social accounts of muller to be fired
that was in november Muller was
appointed in May six months go by why do
you wait for that I'll tell you why he
waited because five days before his
legislation Paul Manafort was indicted
five days before legislation the
indictment Mike Flynn was rumored to be
talking to same one that Comey said
didn't lie when he was interviewed but I
think that in here is we see memos
coming out of the sky and legislation
coming out of this guy when the
Republican Democrat with the House
Republicans are doing Donald Trump will
play poker any time but we hold the Aces
in that poker game when you've got a
circumstance where Muller's team has
strong evidence of bias and still to
this day not a single piece of evidence
that there was any collusion
I mean look when you guys lost this
campaign you had to blame the Russians
you had to blame Bernie Sanders I think
at one point you guys have blamed Jill
Stein I mean at what point does the
Hillary Clinton team say we just lost
cuz we had a worse candidate and Donald
Trump had the more compelling that guys
that way what do you say I am concerned
about Russia meddling in our election I
am concerned about Russian TV I am
concerned about Russia meddling in
elections all over the world they do it
everywhere but here but if you guys
range such as you took an oath to
preserve protect fun watching domestic
what why do you allow Russia which is so
bad that you got beat by a hundred
Russian trolls you guys were spending
millions of dollars every day and you're
saying a hundred Russian trolls are what
guys again I'm here it's public insane
the Russians Democrats finally care
about the Russians because last time I
checked last time I checked they were
trying to like do reset and the button
and you know we were we were smilin with
Putin at conferences and so forth I'm
Carter Paige who obviously is that it
was the target of the surveillance I
interviewed him few weeks back and I
asked him specifically about this guy
Igor Sechin who's mentioned in the
Democrats memo as someone this Steele
dossier claimed he met with I asked him
about that specific individual let's
watch so I gave a speech
and the there was one senior government
official who spoke after me he was
walking out of the the building after he
gave his speech and we had a very brief
conversation for less than 10 seconds
was that Igor Sechin no I've never met
such an in my life you're saying tonight
that you have never met Igor
I always forget his name section you've
never met him I've never met him in my
entire life
look I think in the spirit of bipartisan
comedy I think we could say that quarter
page is the dumbest person in this
entire scandal that's why that's the
characteristic of not being able to
speak on television whatever an empty
but he is the basis he his trip in July
2016 in his work going back as far as
2013-2014 is the basis for the FBI
looking at him so you so you're
comfortable with the fact that in the
end that this memo the the FISA warrant
did not include a reference to Hillary
Clinton well I'll tell you first of all
I want to go blade said that it came
from a post source wouldn't have
bothered you if you were the target of
this investigation the bothered you
would have bothered me friends don't
give an F bi information on your end it
always comes target you wouldn't like
that I can tell you I wouldn't be the
target because I didn't collude or
abstraction look at Carter pain free
judging that guys guys guys stop fully
he can't be both dumb and kind of doing
this super secret spy network sure he
could be a bad spot which is how he got
caught this is how Donald Trump jr. is
is the sharpest knife in the drawer
right there okay well then what I'm
gonna say about Hillary Clinton if the
dumb person ends up winning the election
would say about your people